bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur
air des chances en moins pour commencer
au sujet de cette intervention qui se
veut plutôt optimiste du porte parole du
gouvernement selon lui les chiffres
décline même légèrement mais depuis
plusieurs semaines toutefois est ce que
ça ne se ressent est ce que ça se
ressent dans les hôpitaux
visiblement pas écouté nous sommes à un
taux d'occupation de l'hydre annulation
qui est élevé nous avons des programmes
et des patients donc ça veut dire un
hôpital anciens et une partie de la
population qui ne peut pas bénéficier de
salles de soin adapté donc clair qu'il y
a un problème en termes de capacités
hospitalières
il n'a pas été réglé depuis un an et
c'est ce que nous les longues sans et le
gouvernement nous en annonçant à jour
des compliments qu'apax rn2 très bien à
part une stratégie globale annoncé pour
les mois et les années qui viennent et
on a un problème aujourd'hui sur le
vaccin est réglé nous sommes à deux
salons en france et pour le monde entier
a réclamé l'industrie pharma et laisse
ses problèmes en utilisant ce qui est
plus dans le cadre de l'organisation
mondiale du commerce
c'est à dire la fin du brevet et la
licence de fils et que l'on se met à
produire massivement des vaccins voilà
il faut qu'on utilise toutes les armes à
notre disposition ce qui n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui et surtout le
gouvernement crée une inquiétude
supplémentaire dans la population on en
sent pas les perspectives avec plusieurs
options mais il ne suffit pas que le
président de la république vienne un
soir de manière impromptue nous dire que
après l'été on aura vacciner tout le
monde
moi je le dis clairement le président
macron dans l'état actuel des choses a
menti nous ne sommes pas en capacité
aujourd'hui de vacciner l'ensemble de la
population rythme où les choses se
passent aujourd'hui d'ici la fin de
l'été
vous demandez aussi une augmentation du
nombre de lits en réanimation vous
craignez que la situation ne se
détériore ces prochaines semaines qu'est
ce qui vous inquiète en particulier
écoutez au regard du nombre de lits nous
avons aujourd'hui une un taux
d'occupation qui est très élevé mais
parce que le nombre de lits habituels
n'a pas été augmentée qu'on a envoyé
l'an dernier nous avions dénoncé via le
fait que la france disposait de trois
fois moins de livres animations en
cantons se comparer avec l'allemagne
rapporté à sa population
rien n'a été fait depuis un an pour
augmenter ce nombre de lits rien n'a été
fait or c'est la raison pour laquelle
avec donc les réanimateurs médicaux nous
réclamons que des mesures soient prises
rapidement pour remonter de manière
pérenne de manière pérenne le nombre de
livres animations en france pour les
semaines qui viennent pour l'été
prochain pour l'hiver prochain
polymer l'hiver 2021 2022 parce que nous
aurons besoin de ces lits de réanimation
et nous ne pouvons pas continuer à
fonctionner avec cette tension
permanente à l'hôpital d'une parka les
conséquences sur les patients que l'on
ne peut pas prendre en charge ce que
j'appelle les déprogrammations ce qui
s'appelle les déprogrammations et au
regard de l'épuisement du personnel
actuel et vous savez la luz
nous avons étudié la situation d'un
certain nombre d'hôpitaux avec ces
foyers épidémiques qui a eu dans un
certain nombre d'hôpitaux une des causes
c'est se voie par laquelle mais une des
causes c'est que le personnel est épuisé
et quand vous êtes fatigué et bien vous
êtes beaucoup plus sensibles aux
infections
vous voyez il ya besoin que monsieur
verront monsieur macron nous écoutent et
accepte de discuter d'une stratégie à
court terme à moyen terme à long terme
avec toutes les options ce qui n'est pas
le cas à l'heure actuelle et vous
demandez aussi une augmentation du
nombre des internes jusque là vous
n'avez eu aucun retour de la part du
gouvernement vous ne sentez pas une
prime de conscience de la situation
vécu dans les hôpitaux alors aucune
prise de conscience aucune prise de
conscience nous avons monsieur véran qui
nous remercient régulièrement c'est très
gentil mais qui ne donne aucun moyen
supplémentaire
vous savez l'essentiel des mesures du
ségur ce sont quelques augmentations de
salaire mais aujourd'hui dans mon
hôpital l'assistance publique hôpitaux
de paris
le directeur général poursuit son plan
de restructuration avec en particulier
l'opération appelée hôpital nord qui va
se traduire par la fermeture des
hôpitaux bichat et beaujon et la
suppression de 400 lits alors que nous
manquons de lits aujourd'hui le
directeur général du plus grand hôpital
d'europe qu'est l'assistance
publique-hôpitaux de paris martin hirsch
maintient un plan qui va fermer 400 lits
dans le nord de paris
là où nous aurons le plus c'est parti
mans scandaleux c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous poussons un cri d'alarmé
et que nous réclamons réellement que le
gouvernement ne nous écoute
aujourd'hui la tendance à écouter que
les gens qui sont d'accord avec lui dès
qu'on est un petit peu en contradiction
eh bien on n'est pas reçue au ministère
on nous écoute pas c'est pas sérieux
il ya un véritable problème du niveau
d'un autre tissu hospitalier qui a été
mise à mal ces dernières années avec la
suppression
rappelons le quand même pour vos
téléspectateurs
cent mille lits ont été fermés en france
ces 25 dernières années cent mille lits
et bien ce sont des lits qui nous manque
aujourd'hui donc il va falloir inverser
la courbe est très rapidement autrement
nous aurons de grandes difficultés dans
les mois et dans les années qui viennent
avec une population qui vieillit et des
besoins qui augmentent
comment est ce que vous vous expliquer
aussi d'un mois cette inégalité
territoriale
parce qu'on investit chez les riches et
on laisse les pauvres avec les services
publics dégradés
voilà c'est la logique des libéraux qui
nous gouvernent venez voir mon hôpital à
bobigny la structure architecturale et
on peut la comparer avec l'hôpital
georges-pompidou août et nous en un
hôpital qui ressemble plus au niveau de
ces parties communes au site et de la
seine-saint-denis qui a un véritable
hôpital
voilà moi je suis dans un bâtiment du
samu et pourtant récent qui est très
dégradé là on à l'escalier qui s'est
effondré
quinze jours il n'est toujours pas
réparé aucun entretien n'est fait voilà
on a des le chauffage mais cette nuit ce
matin au au staff vont changement
d'équipé mes collègues se plaignait
d'avoir eu très froid cette nuit pendant
les quelques heures de repos qu'ils ont
pu prendre parce que le chauffage ne
marche pas écoutez quand vous faites une
garde de nuit et vous avez deux heures
pour vous reposer et que vous êtes
obligé de vous reposer dans une chambre
ya pas de chauffage est-ce que c'est
licite dans un pays comme la france est
dans un grand hôpital qui dépend de
l'assistance publique hôpitaux de paris
merci beaucoup d'avoir réagi sur notre
antenne christophe prudhomme porte
parole de l'association médecins
urgentistes de france